[Music]
[Music]
what we're here are we i mean we've been
here for a while but now we're now
officially here in terms of being
recorded we've just been chatting but
now they're going to they're going to
record this chat in this time what's
been going on we've had some very very
shocking weather this morning
rain like you've never seen yeah
rattling off my roof tails i call it the
end of the world weather that kind of
rain you get in la it doesn't tend to
rain at all in l.a and then when it does
it's cats and dogs isn't it when it does
i always imagine you just
screaming and ripping off your top and
just running around the garden do you do
that yeah yeah i do
yeah just with just uh with my clothes
below the waist but above
naked as the day i was born just your
t-shirt folded neatly on the sofa there
i always i look i have a garden which it
throughout most of the year i always
look at it and think oh i'm so sorry
that i can't
get enough water your way because the
even if you water in the garden which i
do the sun burns it off very quickly but
on a day like this
oh my garden's glorious it's like you
can almost like see it breathe in you
can't that's just no you're not getting
yeah it's almost
um
yeah hey we've had some correspondence
we should jump right in because this is
going to be a packed show we've got a
guest
we've got things to get through shall we
do some housekeeping it's non-stop don't
peeling the onion
shall i read the long one please do it i
know you struggle to read this comes
from hope
what lovely name yeah in denver colorado
lovely lovely hope says i'm a big fan of
the podcast i enjoyed hearing about the
mysteries of the universe you were
interested in solving and ali's interest
in the diatlov pass incident it made me
think of a mystery i'm very curious
about and maybe dom's animal expertise
can lend some context to it who knows
who knows have you heard of the bulls
found dead in oregon farms many young
healthy bulls have mysteriously showed
up dead on the ranch drained of blood
and with body parts precisely removed
they haven't been in tracks
found around they haven't been in tracks
found around the balls or teeth marks
that probably doesn't make sense but
that's okay any other marks that could
have been used to extract the blood
stories like this have shown up in
recent years but it sounds like similar
stories have appeared for centuries all
over the us for different large animals
and they gave us a link there now this
is the first time i'm reading this but
drained of blood and with body parts
missing
body parts yeah william please
go on vampira um what the bet yeah just
vampires oh just virtual vampires actual
vampire that's the only it's the only
explanation when you take away all other
options what you're left with it's a
vampire is the truth
which is a vampire vampira vampira and
they their preferred way of getting
blood is from
cows male cows not humans now they've
moved on
they'll take whatever they can get your
vampires you see
mainly i mean it go it's a sliding scale
yeah all the way from you know from like
from chickens yeah they will drain them
to a virgin is the number one choice
yeah they do love them now what about if
they're struggling with they go for like
a b or a wasp would they suck all the
blood out there's not much eating in a
bee for a vampira why are they taking
body parts and what body parts are they
taking well they're taking that you know
you always say that when we do billion
doll meet the world when i say how how
um useful is the the food and you always
think can i take it with me yeah on the
train or that to a football game well
that's what they're doing yeah taking a
leg with them and they'll suck the blood
out of that later oh okay nice nice so
like stuff for the journey back home
yeah they'll stick it in a uh a top a
big top of where yeah and then yeah
yeah they're flying home because they
are half bat aren't they well not with
tupperware so you'd have to walk home so
then if they're getting
found by the police on the walk home i
would say they're probably covered in
blood right because they've just drained
an animal of its blood yeah carrying a
large briefcase size top away through
tupperware
of a cow's leg yeah for a second later
right and no one knows about this no one
takes much noise no do you think if they
if the police did find him they would
probably suck the policeman's blood and
then maybe put a leg in the tupperware
take that with them hope i think we've
solved it
vampires all right billy over to you
another diet lofts incidentally oh dee
at love pass as we talked about so you
know i hope everybody's following us
every week otherwise this will make no
sense yes last year a very compelling
theory was set to solve the enduring
mystery of the
d'atlov pass incident
where in 1959 nine experienced hikers
died on the slopes of kolat
ciacar
mountain death mountain as it's known
the hikers the study put forward were
caught in a rare
slab avalanche
now soviet authorities at the same
established that three die duty physical
trauma the others from hypothermia being
caught in the avalanche is a good
explanation hitting a third of the group
while the rest met their demise as they
fled in unsuitable closing on suitable
clothing like laid a hose in maybe a
pair of cycling shirts well it could be
anything it could be an evening gone
green on red which you should never do
yeah red and green should never be seen
except in an irish queen oh
so while the explanation fitted the
peculiarities
i think scottish person to say
not everyone was convinced the main
criticism was that avalanches were not
seen in this mountain
well since the publication authors
johann guam and alexander m puzrun
conducted three more expeditions to that
mountain and found video evidence of two
recent avalanches so i think if you look
in the communications earth and
environment journal you'll see that it
could well have been an avalanche are
you saying that we've just solved the
diatolof pass incident
yes
kennedy next
now but through the looking glass here
dog yeah we are now we've had what's
this this is regarding twist on mystery
by
bob wade i don't know
let me give you the monkey's poor twist
do it then you can turn into anything oh
you'll only be able to do it once
interesting you'll be a dragon a dust
mite an elephant anything but choose
wisely because once you make that choice
and change you are stuck as whatever
you've changed into and cannot change
back so you and i can turn into anything
but only one time
don't do it can't be another human
should we say that otherwise yeah
otherwise you know i mean
i'm gonna choose go on because i'm still
thinking
a blue whale
whopper i want to be the biggest thing
that has ever been
and really no predators once it gets to
adult side as a kid it does have some
predators yeah but who's going to attack
a blue whale like a killer whale i would
i would swipe away well mum's generally
with the kids so the mum would give it
what for yeah and if anything i would
just dive deep deep deep deep
can you do it
and a great thing deep down well there's
no fish except ones we just that are a
mouth and a light and there's those
animals that go
it's just
it's non-descript but right there's very
deep bottoms of the sea there's a thing
it's got it's got like a
thing here yeah and if you guys get an
eyelash thing and if you get closer it
goes
scary we're going right so because i
could go anywhere well no you can go to
like debenhams or like miss selfridge
you mean any body of water anywhere well
salt water tennis can out salt water
they don't they don't go in anything
they do they and they just normal water
and you see how whales station whales
swim like this yeah but fish as we know
swim like this yeah so you know you know
why well swim like this which is a
mammal then because why they do that why
what's the what's the reason because why
wouldn't you swim like that yeah
serpentine movement is one of the most
um satisfying movements in in nature
yeah and just so what's that one called
i don't know because that's the way
thing me the man from atlanta swims
right mermaids as well and merman i'd
assume why do they i don't know because
whales used to live on the land
and this is them running ah wait no it's
true
whales evolved from being a land
dwelling creature that made their way
into the ocean not the other way around
and most other things did the other way
around am i right well some of them did
i mean most life on earth began in the
ocean right but so ultimately if you go
all the way back right probably the the
forefathers of a whale began in the
ocean because all life began there they
came out for a while it came out what
size was it oh the whoppers they became
terrestrial then they they made their
way back into the ocean and you can find
the remnants of legs
in wales
the country yeah yeah
wait i've not picked mine so you'd be a
blue whale give us some of your blue
whale stats
what stats come on you know a few great
stats about blue whales blue whale's
heart is the size of a volvo it's a mini
cooper but man fair enough its tongue
is the size
of mexico
sure
is that true
a bit smaller a grown man can swim down
its blood vessels
yeah but they never have
and it can hold its breath
for over a hundred years
incredible
and being the biggest animal on the
planet yep they can't eat anything
bigger than a tennis ball
and they're the biggest that's ever been
yeah so it's not just the biggest now no
no bigger than all the dinosaurs not put
together no individually individually
individually the biggest animal that has
ever been on this planet yeah because it
is oh water is the only thing that would
allow that animal to sustain that size
that's why the african elephant the
biggest land-dwelling creature you
couldn't get anything bigger than that
because its bones would fracture on
earth but in the water as we know
looks after you yeah it's buoyant
right so you turn into the blue well
my goodness i would turn into
oh that's tough choose well because you
can't try and come back you can't come
back from it it's the monkey's paw
experiment
i probably i'll probably say a golden
eagle
large bird not too many predators lives
in the highlands of scotland oh
big
you know almost effortless flight how
high can they fly
i would say like 20 feet 22 feet
can you fly fast not it's not the
fastest bird of prey that's the
peregrine falcon but
yeah extremely
graceful no predators
yeah just fl i mean flying come on
flying yeah beautiful kidding me hey
thanks bob wade yeah that was good that
we've had some miss heard lyrics we like
this we've got a few here go on you go
first right you know when a la isla
bonita is playing in a it's last night i
dreamed of san pedro
as you know
well well um this person and we don't
have the name says
last night i stepped on a lego last
night i stepped on a lego
lovely stuff this from not all is
wonderful at youtube my favorite miss
hurdler it came out of my
eight-year-old's mouth at the time she
at the time but she's now 16. instead of
hit me with your best shot by pat
benatar yeah she thought it was hit me
with your pet chalk oh that was good
good actually yeah it's good
dom last one
all right it's one from steven x and
this is a dried pirate robert who said
for the longest time i thought the song
white winged dove by stephen x was one
winged dove
it would only be as flying circles
wouldn't it yeah he always thought that
was very strange and cruel very sad uh
we've also got some ques no more tongue
twisters this week so send them in
because you love the tongue twisters
right question here from lenny in sorry
he's age 30. hey
excuse me hello lenny so my dad used to
have butter oh on his weetabix for
supper
so are there any other strange things
you have put butter on and how else do
you like your cereal
dom how do you feel about your character
beaumont kin being partially cut from
star wars the raza skywalker and do you
think jj abrams will ever release the
director's cut you asked for uh you know
most characters get partially cut down
yeah it's annoying you don't tend to uh
get all of your stuff in there obviously
i would have liked to have seen more
yeah that's just the way it goes i was i
was only in the last story in that
trilogy and they had to finish off a
whole bunch of other stories do i think
jj will release the director's cut well
jj doesn't own the movie that's owned by
disney so that would be more of a disney
question yeah do you think mickey mouse
will ever release it
should we say maybe yeah let's say maybe
and then
is there anything strange that you put
butter on and how else do you like your
cereal i sometimes like my cereal dry
just do that only if i take a handful
that's what i mean i'll have the yeah
yeah i mean i have like handfuls of
maybe magic spoon cereal delicious
freebie there magic spoon there you go
it's very good
strange things you put butter on
that has gone back to like the first
episode of the friendship onion we
talked about butter then did we yeah way
way back
and uh you put it on your back no never
i i like buttered dough oh i like butter
i do like it remember my mum telling me
like 10 15 years ago if she could eat
anything with no consequences bread and
butter and i thought it was a bit boring
and now i think bread and butter i mean
good fresh bread that bread that you
baked was
melting i'm gonna beat that tomorrow
delightful that it's delightful with a
don't mind it's
nice good but a good butter
we all love fizzy drinks when we were
kids right but we've come to learn
that fizzy sodas and sugary drinks are
probably not good for you but there is a
new kind of soda and it's called
lollipop it tastes just like the sodas
that we all grew up with but unlike
other sodas that are full of sugar corn
syrup and artificial ingredients like
aspartame lollipop is made with natural
ingredients that are actually good for
you lollipop is the fastest growing
functional beverage brand in america
they have delicious nostalgic flavors
like vintage cola classic root beer
orange squeezed cherry vanilla
strawberry vanilla and their newest
flavor classic grape they use functional
ingredients that combine the benefits of
probiotics plant fiber and botanicals to
support your microbiome and benefit
digestive health 90 of americans consume
more than the usda's daily recommended
added sugar intake which is 30 grams
sweetened beverages like fizzy drinks
sodas are the leading source of added
sugars in the american diet receive 20
off plus free shipping on your order i
recommend trying their variety pack this
is a great way of trying all their
delicious flavors go to drink lollipop
dot com slash onion or use code onion at
checkout to claim this deal that's d r i
n k
o l i p o p dot com slash onion lollipop
can be found in over 8 000 stores across
the country including kroger target
whole foods sprouts and wegmans
is much more than diet and exercise
research increasingly shows that a
healthy gut microbiome is crucial to a
healthy life pendulum glucose control is
the first and only medical probiotic
clinically shown to help manage type 2
diabetes when taken with medication over
time people with type 2 diabetes lose
the gut bacteria to help them digest
fiber and manage blood glucose levels
for those with type 2 diabetes diet and
exercise alone are not enough just to
manage it the best approach emphasizes
diet exercise and a healthy gut
if you struggle to manage these levels
with diet and exercise alone your gut
microbiome might need attention pendulum
glucose control helps fill in the gaps
between diet and exercise pendulum's
team of scientists doctors and
innovators isolated the unique strains
of beneficial gut bacteria that help
people with type 2 diabetes manage their
blood sugar levels if you or someone you
love has type 2 diabetes take control of
glucose levels with pendulum glucose
control use code onion pendulum life dot
com to get 20 off your first month of
membership that's p e n
d u l u m
i
dot com promo code onion for 20 after
your first month of membership
hey talking about food dom yeah go on
you weren't here when we had the lovely
casper life on the lovely casper we did
go for lunch though oh we did so you met
him
and uh he was he was kind enough to cook
the greatest cake
and all christendom yeah you said it was
oh it's like is that piece for me
it's called a dream dream cake
tremendous or something like that
similar danish accent is absolutely
perfect
it sounds like you were born in
copenhagen oh yeah yeah yeah it's not
right like he's dropped it steady itself
now it's like lego oh hold on are you
gonna have the big bit no i'll take it a
little bit
if you wash your hands because i know
you were recently vomiting when when
where how long ago do you want me i mean
i'd say sometime in the last three hours
since you've vomited i have washed my
hands since okay but i have i did go for
a pee there that's all right i'll wash
my hands there as well we're almost
familiar here
i'll just use my fingers
look at please
pissy fingers they call them are you
ready yeah pass it over here it comes
down not only did you describe this i
think you gave it a 10 out of 10 for
taste or a 9.9 never give an 8 and 10
nothing's perfect 9.9 not only did you
give this almost perfect score but
johnny close said it was the best cake
he's ever had now it's been frozen
but it's not frozen now just give me a
minute all right eat sake hang us
has it gone then
wow
i remember you saying halfway through
the bit you said for god's sake please
someone bring me a cup of coffee now i
understand now you get it it's got that
kind of
the combination of coffee in your mouth
it's like a wonderful soupy mixture
oh it's moorish isn't it not moorish and
it nice though moist oh you want to talk
about moist and this has been frozen
that's been frozen as well tom a week
ago caspar an incredible achievement i
sincerely hope that he left you the
recipe in the method not only do we have
the recipe that he gave me and i think
it was from his grandmother or something
but we'll stick it up on the friendship
onion
um on our website and everyone can try
and make it and just enjoy themselves
i mean imagine this morning in the rain
you had to go to the store right to buy
yourself some milk you're running out of
milk or something yeah yeah and you were
running and you're in the raindrop
and when you came in
soaking wet yeah hand you a towel i said
there's a nice cup of tea there tom and
some dream cakes
lovely i'd love that this is one of the
greatest things i've put in my mouth and
i've put some pretty incredible things
in my mouth over there isn't that
delicious nutritious and delicious i
love a coconut too
what do you think of that yeah
i'm arguing at scores or not well you
don't have to but do you think you
should saw it last week what go on give
a score double episode a billion dollars
i'll very quickly give it scores taste i
could see why you almost gave it a
perfect score it's incredible i'm gonna
say the same as you nine nine point nine
out of ten
that is a fantastic cake
looks
it got demoted last week because it does
you know it's quite a bland looking cake
isn't it just i like the look of it
and then usefulness
i mean it's a cake isn't it the end of
the day i wouldn't mind a little
dream cake ice cream
little tiny like tiny little spheres of
this in a vanilla ice cream so now
you've got frozen
dream cake which that was yesterday
8.2 no bad dogs i loved it
i'll finish that as we're talking hi
we've got a um we've got a guest well
we've got i guess we've got another
question well
john's saying he's making a helicopter
john said he's doing this yeah this
means why does it wind up we got we had
some incredible you're talking too much
he's saying okay well end up with us
sometimes we've got an amazing guest
yeah
should we introduce our guest before we
bring him on dom would you please squirt
a manner i'll do the first part with my
glasses
oh there's up to your left knee right
i'll do the first paragraph and you can
do the second our guest today
uh who i'm sure you guys have seen in
some of your favorite movies is mr doug
jones ooh and his biography reads like
this doug jones born may 24th 1960 is an
american actor contortionist
and mime artist that might be a clue he
is best known for portraying non-human
creatures usually featuring heavy makeup
and visual effects he has most notably
collaborated with the acclaimed
filmmaker guillermo del toro who was at
the oscars last night appearing in the
films mimic hellboy pan's labyrinth held
by the golden army crimson peak and the
wonderful oscar-winning shape of water
oh but jonesy's other roles include
dom
it's a list that's a list
hocus pocus tank girl cabinet of dr
caligari
fantastic for
uh i mean ouija the origins of evil the
bye-bye man the strain
and of course plays captain saro in star
trek discovery
let's see if we can talk to our our
wonderful new friend doug jones
here he is what a fantastic guest we've
got this week we've got mr doug jones
and uh i'm really looking forward to
this doug i've been a huge fan of your
work for a long time
and uh we were very excited when you
agreed to come on to the friendship
onion
well i i it felt like an odd fit for me
but and yet but you promised that that
it was going to be a good fit so i i
have to trust
absolutely well i don't know if you know
but me and john
are actors and we're not very good
actors we're not like you doug but um
we're very excited
i'm aware i'm aware of it
we're very excited to talk about your um
process and and some of the the amazing
characters that you've brought to life
and uh for me personally um
i suppose
i i would love to like sort of go back
to the start and i know that
your background was mime
and uh
that sort of stuff and i was wondering
was that through
an acting college or was that just
through your own just something that you
wanted to learn
well uh if i went to a state university
ball state university in indiana
here in the us and and i uh i learned
the art of mime from a
a mime troupe on campus called mime over
matter it's a play on words there
that i had no idea that would be early
training for what was to come of my
career you know
in this school you were uh is this the
same school where you were the the
school mascot
did that come through the main one the
main group
so what was the mascot called and what
was it
well it was a we were the fighting
cardinals so it was a big bird suit a
big red bird suit with floppy yellow
feet and very skinny bird legs which i
have
uh that worked out well
brilliant
now doug so before you went to
college and and school and stuff like
that
when you were when you were as we say in
britain and nipper
were you interested in acting were you
interested in films was this something
that you that you wanted to do like when
did when did the fire kind of kick in
for you
yeah that would have been when i was an
awkward child uh as we all felt like
that when we were kids i didn't know i
thought i was the only awkward child and
so you grow up and you find out
everybody felt like that but uh i
i was a very tall skinny goofy kid with
a very long skinny neck that was made
fun of by other kids so
finding uh
inspiration on television like with don
knotts in the mayberry show or gilligan
from gilligan's island or anybody from
the carol burnett show just funny people
on tv were like oh
maybe that's where i belong so that's
kind of what what my early inspirations
were
so at that point so as a as a young
as a youngster you always wanted to be
an actor and then obviously that took
you
to college when
when did you think
that maybe you'd like to lean towards
more of the the physical approach to
acting
i never thought that i never sought that
out actually i i came out to
hollywoodland thinking that i would be a
goofy sitcom sidekick
i had very low aspirations i just wanted
to be like a second fiddle on some show
just kind of coming in as the goofy
neighbor uh and say hey can i borrow a
cup of sugar do an armpit fart say
something funny and leave that's all
that's all i really wanted and uh so but
then being six three and weighing 135
pounds and having a mime background the
creature affects people uh kind of like
whoa
kind of uh uh
you know that grabbed me early on in my
career when i was doing tv commercials
my first agent saw that contortionist
thing on my resume and mime thing on my
resume and sent me out for anything that
involved physical tomfoolery or you know
physical comedy or
any kind of costume work or miming work
or clowning
that's what they were sitting out on and
those roles often came with a look that
was either glued on to you or slipped on
and zipped up the back
so
that's how i kind of got acquainted with
the creature affects people in hollywood
but from doing those kind of commercials
early on and then that's a very
tight-knit community
so as you guys have worked with many
many actors in rubber bits um
uh you know that that there's uh the
creature effects makeup people are a
very tight-knit community that all know
each other and once you're in that
community and you get referred again and
again and again
and i think you know from watching your
characters uh for years
it it kind of made me think of my time
at
drama school show off and
and uh there was a class that we used to
have which was um
psychological uh masks
so this this great teacher would make
these paper mache masks you know that
would totally change your face
and he would make you stare at the
mirror
for sort of 10 minutes
not you know just kind of
trying to figure out what is this face
doing to my body and and how does it
change
and that
i might be wrong you can tell us but it
feels to me
rather than someone just
throwing a costume on you
or a prosthetic it feels like you spend
time
your physicality you can see as
influenced by
how it looks it's not like you've yeah
you can tell me i'm totally wrong here
but it doesn't feel like
you've created a character and then a
prosthetics thrown on top of it it feels
like you have studied this prosthetic
and and
grew into the body that you then have or
or the face that you then have i'd love
to hear a little bit of your um how you
go about that
yeah uh the uh the process is all of the
above
i i have to do all of the
work that an actor has to do with uh you
know all the information we get from the
script with the writer's intention for
that character his wants needs loves uh
fears all those things and how i
interact with other characters then when
you add a fantastical look to it that
brings a whole other element of
information in for what this character
is where he comes from
uh so
and and
even playing human beings you have to
play the character from head to toe i
believe so that would take on you take
on a new posture and a new gesturing
system with every every human you play
so add to that uh some animal instincts
or some alien instincts or things that
you have to infuse into this
and the look helps inform a lot of that
you know especially if i rehearse if i
if i if i read a script and think oh
this character is going to be doing this
with his arms above his head the entire
movie and they get the suit on and it's
like this is all you can do what do you
have to kind of alter
what you have you know rehearsed or
thought in your mind so so it very much
is a
a a community
that has to come together to create this
character and i'm just a part of it yeah
green chefs keto and paleo options give
you the premium proteins and vital
veggies you need to conquer your day
with fresh produce premium proteins and
organic ingredients you can trust green
chef is the number one meal kit for
eating well green chef's mediterranean
preferences pack together fresh flavors
and premium proteins green chef makes
cooking easy so you can spend less time
stressing and more time enjoying
delicious home-cooked meals green chef's
pre-made and pre-measured sauces
dressings and spices get you more chef
curated flavor in less time avoid long
lines at the grocery store green chef is
so convenient with pre-portioned easy to
follow recipes that are delivered right
to your door green chef saves you time
by cutting down on weekly meal planning
prepping and grocery shopping i recently
got an order the great thing about green
chef is there's no waste i got a kind of
high protein kind of box because i was
going to the gym a lot make all your
food and at the end of your meal there's
nothing to throw away it's absolutely
fantastic go to greenchef.com
onion130
and use the code
onion130 to get 130 off plus free
shipping go to greenchef.com
onion130 use the code onion130 to get
130 off plus free shipping green chef
the number one meal kit for eating well
it can be hard to see the light at the
end of the tunnel when you have high
interest debt and sometimes it can be
even harder to ask for help that's where
upstart comes in we've all been there
seemingly out of nowhere you get hit by
an unexpected expense or bill when that
happens it can feel like the weight of
the world is coming down and it's normal
to not know where to turn luckily
upstart is here to help
upstar powered personal loans can help
you pay down high interest debt all
online with simple and easy to
understand payment terms upstart has
helped over 1.8 million customers on
their path to financial freedom whether
it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses upstart can
help you get one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff date upstate knows
you're more than just a credit score so
rather than looking at your credit score
alone upstart's model considers other
factors like your income employment and
other information provided in your loan
application to find you a smarter rate
for your loan you can check your rate in
minutes for loans between 1000 to fifty
thousand dollars without impacting your
credit score you can even receive funds
as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan
don't wait and check your rate today at
upstart.com that's upstart.com
onion to check your rate today don't
forget to use our url to let them know
we sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com onion
and how over over the course of your
career you you've worked with a lot of
prosthetics so
that's a skill set that maybe you could
speak to
for people
watching the show that might want to be
working with prosthetics whether
creating them or as an actor what are
the things that are helpful to you when
you approach a job that does have a lot
of prosthetics as opposed to a job that
has none oh right well uh first of all i
get a lot of young actors uh getting a
hold of me on the social medias like i
want to do what you do and my answer is
oh save yourself
oh you're kidding me
uh yeah
but
uh but no but if it's uh
if you're either
as a performer in a crazy look
you you want to you have to really be
you have to think like an athlete and an
actor because you you do once this look
is on you it might take anywhere from
two to seven hours to get you into that
look every day
your energy then has to be up on camera
for the next 12 hours and then you have
to get cleaned up for the next two hours
after that you may have a turnaround for
the next day that is less than
than ideal you might sleep four hours
maybe and then have to be back at it all
over again the next day so you really do
have to be in the best shape of your
life uh and and you know take care of
yourself with all of the physical stuff
you know hydrate and take your vitamins
and get your sleep and all that stuff
uh if you can but
when it comes to the creature effects
the creators uh
of you know if you if you're one of
those kids who doodled in your notebook
during math class and you're drawing
pictures of demons and fighting angels
uh that's those are the people that
usually end up creating the looks that
have gone on me
and uh
so i would say keep keep that art artist
in you very much alive
even if nobody's buying it yet just keep
creating the art
because it needs to be made and and
when if and when it's good enough
it will be it will be seen it will be
purchased nice and what do you think
thus far
in in your career has been the most
tricky
prosthetics pieces to work with
what's the most arduous job that you've
done up to now
oh gosh well uh none of them are easy i
just you know but
i and well let's start with an easy one
like or as far as like
the more human you are the easier it's
going to be such as uh when i played
billy butcherson and hocus pocus uh that
was a human who had been dead for 300
years so that involved basically head
and hands uh
you know
it was a prosthetic yes but it was you
know just a
hollowed out
cheekboney zombie dead guy kind of
decayed look
uh with slip-on gloves super easy and a
big wig
on the other side of the spectrum would
be
like something
uh you know the farther from human you
get the harder it's going to be so that
would be like the fawn from pan's
labyrinth where i was in stilts making
me seven feet tall and had ram horns on
my head that was a very heavy
costume and makeup combination i i
delineate the two like a costume is
something you slip on and zip up the
back a makeup is something glued to you
or painted on your person yeah so and so
a lot of these characters are a
combination of both of those the
amphibian man from the shape of water is
another example of a combination uh
they're in so
so
those are the more difficult ones that
involve mechanics
and glued on makeup bits uh and i've
often had like both both of my fishman
character abe safian from the hellboy
movies and the amphibian man from the
shape of water had mechanical gills that
were right here by my ears and as
they're puppeteered from off camera uh
they're going
it's just like
and
so you really have to concentrate yeah
concentrate through that yeah
and uh and try to just kind of make that
a part of the fish's ecosystem it's like
you know he this is what he hears it's
like tinnitus in his ears that's what he
has okay i get it so i can i can act
through that i love that i love the sort
of
making it work for you on a sort of
day-to-day basis that you you just make
that oh yeah this is a thing that this
character
has
like if we can talk about the shape of
water um which if anyone hasn't seen it
you should
watch it tonight it's an incredible film
yeah i love the movie and
how you and the director and everyone
involved
got that
romance to make sense and be beautiful
and
and and so touching was was really
incredible and um
i think after that when i went back and
watched a lot of you work again and that
sort of
truth and and sort of
elegance that you bring to characters is
is really special
and
like for that that for that film um
thinking about that one
were you in water
like
a lot of the day
or was there special effects that they
used i don't know wind tunnels or
something to kind of
to give effects or were you stuck in a
stuck in a tank for
all day it was a little bit of both yes
uh depending on the scene uh now
in the scenes where i was in the
laboratory there was a pool in there
that was actual water that i had to dive
into come up out of be in living for
weeks at a time
but the
but if i was in a tank with the tank
with the glass around it
uh that would have been
a dry tank with me on a on a a seesaw
sort of thing so they could get the
floaty
action out of me
and they would pump they pump some smoke
in there and then rippling lighting
effect looked like water uh the final
scene of the movie where we are uh
floating away in into happily ever after
together underwater
that was the that was sally hawkins and
me in hip harnesses strung up in a huge
studio also filled with smoke with a
rippling light effect from above and
fans blowing on us to get like a
you know to get her clothing to move
and her hair was pinned up on one side
so they could cg the the the floaty hair
thing later wow in post-production
and add bubbles in and all that so we
were we were hanging from very painful
hip harnesses for most of that day
but the bathroom scene where we uh where
she stuffs towels under the door and
floods the room so we can have a little
hoo-ha underwater
uh
she
that that was that was the bathroom set
was been rebuilt in a tank that was
eight feet deep
and uh we they did actually show that
with water and film us under underwater
so we had to
kind of like expel
all the air out of your lungs so you can
sink and then do your thing and then
hopefully you hear cut over the
loudspeaker that's under the water
uh we kind of prayed for that please cut
already
so it's a combination of a few things i
mean i remember
when we did rings
pete jackson showing us the footage of
elijah falling into the mid-water
marshes and kind of you know being in a
trance yeah he puts on the ring at that
point right i can't remember or maybe
just kind of passes out
and that was all done in a in a kind of
wind tunnel and this that's what made me
that's what made me think of that
because sean aston as well as some wise
uh when he goes in the water that was
all done in a wind tunnel so a little
bit of slow motion a little bit of wind
and a little bit of light and i remember
showing it to us on a tiny little
monitor
and saying pretty good right and i was
like i remember thinking yeah it's good
but i didn't realize what he was saying
which was there's no water
and then and then he said that's
a wind tunnel and i was like what that
makes no sense but it's a great trick
isn't it yeah it's a maker i was
wondering because i just thought it was
you know was dug and water for like four
months that would have been hell
especially in a prosthetic because how
did they even
how did they keep the prosthetic from
like disintegrating or falling off and
i mean just for that say that film alone
talk us through
what a day would be for you yeah
becoming uh that character like that
must have been a long prosthetic
well it wasn't as long as as some of
them because it was
i remember that suit makeup delineation
this was more suit yeah with makeup
around the face and neck but but the
body was slipped on and zipped up uh
but it was so tight and so form fitting
every nook and cranny of me was was
sculpted too
so it fit it fit with such precision
that it took three grown adults to
shimmy this onto me and that took us
about 20 minutes of our start the start
of our day just to get that on my body
then the rebuilding of everything else
around my head and neck and hands um so
that was about a three hour makeup
process
then during the day
uh i actually was
able to sit in a chair between between
takes and shots
and i did i had a fine backside i'm not
uh the design process for this took
about a year
because uh
guillermo del toro being the director
that he is the perfectionist that he is
which i really appreciate about him
uh he wanted this fish man to be
so
believable as a romantic figure and you
know when i first got this role he said
dougie you're going to be the romantic
leading man of this movie and i'm like
wow in a fish suit this is a only he
could pull that off so
so
so the sculpting job of this character
uh the the colors and shapes that they
went through retooling constantly were
the the lips and the butt were the two
areas that that needed the most
is it right yet is it kissable is it
grabbable what do you think so uh so
so i knew i knew we had uh that it was
working
when i'm on set in my chair between
things and i often would just save my
energy for the camera like i would also
be falling asleep but i stood up to walk
away from our set chairs at one point
and octavia spencer one of my
wonderful co-stars
all i heard her say was
so i knew that it worked
i love that it's a nice seal of approval
there
um
yeah uh one of our one of our co-stars
on
uh lord rings john reese davies who
plays gimli the dwarf
um had to wear
just a little bit more facial
prosthetics than than billy and i we we
wore
wigs and ears and feet but john had a
kind of was it a nose over the cheek and
someone's head i think yeah yeah and
unfortunately they found out relatively
quickly in the rehearsal process that he
would have quite a strong
reaction to the chemicals needed to
either apply the prosthetics or take
them off so then he had to have at least
two or three days off in between i think
it what maybe even a week just to
recover because his eyes would would get
sore and stuff have you
because obviously prosthetics have
changed over the years doug and they've
and they're consistently getting better
and better but have you had any strong
reactions to prosthetics over the years
no thankfully i've never had any uh
allergies or any problems with no of
course when you're when something is
glued to you and peeled off and glued to
you and peeled off uh or removed there's
chemicals involved and there's gonna be
some wear and tear over over time but
but uh but nothing out of the ordinary
you know in fact joan rivers asked me
this very question on the red carpet at
the oscars in 2007
when pans labyrinth was there with six
nominations
and uh uh she
she asked me about this uh
uh we're doing a little interview
and she said uh i but i'd wanted to talk
to her all my life by the way we're all
aware who joan rivers is right and she's
a hilarious comedian
who was very well known for having lots
and gobs of work done uh you know
with plastic surgeries and things
so so she's asking me
being someone who's worn so much you
know prosthetic makeups and things have
you ever had any problems with that with
you know a rash or an allergic reaction
to anything and bringing your products i
said so no i i thankfully i've never had
any bad reactions to
adhesives or removers or latex products
or silicone products and as i was saying
the words silicone products i'm i'm
looking at her precious face just
stuffed full of them
so
so
so i couldn't help myself and i said
well you know what i mean
on worldwide television thank you that's
like
i've been wanting to meet her all my
life and that's how that's what i do to
her i love it
you recently played a role in in doom
patrol that had a
pretty significant amount of facial
prosthetics right yeah it did and i've
i've always been kind of interested in
prosthetics and i don't know if you know
this doug but me and dom and the other
two hobbits were in the guinness book of
records ones for
the longest time
in uh uh makeup chair for one job
because we were there for about two
years and we would do three hours every
morning so even though it's nothing like
some of the ones that you've done but it
accumulated you know so
spending a long time in a makeup chair
and i think i read somewhere is this
right that you got an award from the
i think the i don't know who it was from
the makeup
um union there's something
it's called the chair yeah the award
the the chair award was kind of a
lifetime achievement sort of thing for
someone outside the makeup and hair
union that has been in their chairs a
lot so i that was a quite an honor they
created this award and i was just this
year and i was the first recipient of it
so
nice very very
very very lovely to be represent
recognized by that uh union of of
wonderful artists yeah and by the way i
uh want i i i you guys may not remember
this but i think i met both of you back
in
1999 or 2000 when did the first lord of
the rings movie come out
i was doing a lot of drinking then so
i think it was it's a lot
i think 2 000 i think yeah
was it on a red carpet
because if so i had to be heavily
medicated i was probably carrying an iv
behind me no
was i on bailey's back right right no
it was at a
a charity
vaudeville variety show
you were in the audience and i was on
stage doing a mime act
um
and
i i'm sure it was youtube because then
one of the producers of the show uh bo
well marley shelton was actress marley
shelton was was
uh
uh producing the event and her fiance at
the time now husband beau uh
uh
came back to me backstage and said uh
two of the hobbits from lord of the
drinks would love to meet you right so i
actually met both of you yeah and you
used the f word you actually used the f
word saying like you were amazing that
was the best thing i have so funny
was so sweet of both of you so i
dumb lovely stuff well here we go it was
a fantastic chat we might see him on the
convention circuit and that would be
fantastic uh of course guys remember if
you're enjoying the french bunion and
you're not subscribing why aren't you
subscribing please subscribe to the
french bunny give us a nice review and a
five star rating you can also leave
comments on our youtube channel send us
your tongue twisters send us your
riddles and tongue twisters we've not
had a riddle or a tongue twister for a
while and i love that segment i love
that and if you've got a sweary word
that you'd like to see and load the
rings please send us that as well and if
you want you look fantastic wear the
merch where the friendship onion
merchandise you can get that at the
friendshiponionpodcast.com you certainly
can and if there's any particular food
item or beverage item that you want us
to check out for billion don't meet the
world we'll do that too and
we'll see you next week see you next
week on the friendship onion toodles
[Music]
harmonize with me and hold me back all
through the night you're shining bright
i'm your host the baby you're my
[Music]